three paparazzi in the owner of a gossip
magazine are among six people on trial
in France over topless photos of the
Duchess of Cambridge now the pictures
were published back in 2012 that's the
year after Kate Middleton married Prince
William the alleged invasion of privacy
outraged Britain's royal family Jonathan
Vigliotti is at the gates of Kensington
Palace that's in London with how the
photos are bringing back a painful
episode for Prince William Jonathan good
morning good morning the palace calling
these photos a grotesque invasion of
privacy
comparing the paparazzi that took them
to the paparazzi that hounded Princess
Diana this lawsuit meant to prevent
history from repeating itself
the Duke and Duchess were all smiles in
France and March on their first official
visit to the country but this of course
was a planned photo shoot it's the
unplanned one that happened at this
Chateau in 2012 that has them firing
back at French media prosecutors were in
court yesterday hearing the case filed
by the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge
against photographers and publishers of
closer the gossip magazine is charged
with invading the privacy of Kate by
snapping and printing topless photos of
her Kadesh Moscow sent a lawyer for the
magazine justified the publication on
public interest grounds saying in court
the pictures disproved rumours
circulating at the time that the Duchess
might be anorexic the photos were taken
from a long lens camera while the couple
was on vacation
well correspondent Roy Anika was with
the couple when the story broke and said
they had every expectation of privacy
they do have an expectation of privacy
and even when they go to public places
if they're going on holiday to private
home then they then have a full
expectation of privacy just like any
other member the public
Prince William submitted a statement to
the court saying the photographs were
shocking and all the more painful given
the harassment linked to the death of
his mother Princess Diana was hounded by
the press until the day she died in a
car crash in Paris 20 years ago after
being chased by paparazzi through the
city I don't think Diana's death you
know which William and Harry still feel
the paparazzi caused her death I don't
think it's really made them
much more timid when it comes to trying
to get photographs often elicits
photographs members of a family the
problem being there is still a wide
audience there still public interest
French authorities have already banned
reproduction of the topless pictures but
the images still appeared in several
other publications across Europe here at
the palace they're asking for 1.6
million dollars in damages enough money
they hope to make photographers and
publishers think twice in the future
Nora the court expected to hand down its
decision later this summer all right
Jonathan Vigliotti and London thank you
so much